Modern engineering focuses
on rotating motors
to power almost any machine.
It has taken about 200 years
for motors to become what they are today.
And they're still loud
and unnatural in their ways.
The constant noise of machines
causes problems
for living beings everywhere,
both in the ocean and also on land.
Humans who are constantly exposed to noise
can become stressed, depressed
and even develop tinnitus.
In contrast,
there are no rotating motors in nature.
Nature often smoothly,
glides, swims or wiggles,
without the rattling of rigid parts
or the loud rubbing of surfaces.
I believe we can and should rehaul
our approach to how we make machines.
Instead of using rigid
or unnatural materials,
what if we made biomimetic machines?
Machines made of soft or living materials
that are adaptive and safe to use
in a variety of everyday tasks?
Can you imagine boats
or submarines that propel themselves
by moving their tails from side to side,
just like fish do?
So to imitate these natural movements,
we have to replace rotating motors
and fast, spinning propellers
with artificial muscles.
And I can tell you this, this can be done.
Our team of researchers
at MIT and ETH Zurich
has started to develop
less disruptive robots
by introducing a new, biomimetic way
of moving through water.
We created a biomimetic robotic fish.
Her name is Sophie.
She's the first demonstration
of a fully untethered, soft robot
that can explore the ocean
without the need for propellers.
Sophie pumps water back and forth
within a highly deformable tail.
Her tail movement imitates the natural
swimming motion of real fish.
Sophie's natural design allows her
to closely monitor aquatic life.
Now, there's a catch.
Sophie is energy-hungry and loud.
Yes, we successfully managed
to build a robot that swims like a fish,
but...
Sophie requires a motor
and a pump to properly work.
Now we are replacing that motor and pump,
which is noisy and not
desired in such a way,
we're replacing it with silent,
artificial muscles.
These muscles are called HASELs.
They directly and efficiently
convert electrical energy
into muscle contractions.
Take a look at this large muscle
we made to lift and lower a leg.
A stack of flexible sheets
contracts and relaxes
just like a thigh muscle does.
Let me tell you how this works.
So we take laminated sheets
to create pouches.
We have several of these pouches
within a single muscle.
We now take a conductive ink
and spray-coat that ink
onto these pouches,
and then we inject them with oil.
After having done this,
we have a conductive ink that acts
like a flexible electrode
that squeezes these liquid-filled pouches
when a voltage is applied.
Now, just like muscles with real fish,
we take this kind of filmed muscles
and pair them up as antagonistic pairs
and put them into our soft
robotic fish design.
We 3D-print the hull
and the spine of this fish,
using soft and rigid materials.
The fish now swims silently
by electrically charging the muscles
inside of the fish
in an alternating fashion
from one side to the other.
To improve our designs,
we do not rely on tedious
trial and error fabrication.
Instead, our software rapidly simulates
and optimizes a design for performance
before we have to build it.
Our approach creates
a continuous design space
that interpolates between existing
fish designs to create new designs.
Our optimization then explores
this continuous design space
to come up with new and faster creatures
we have not seen before.
Robots one day might even be made
of living muscle cells.
Wouldn't it be great if such a living
robot would then heal itself,
just like human muscles do?
I can tell you this.
Starting from muscle cells,
we can already print,
grow and stimulate muscles.
We are now beginning to make
these muscles larger,
longer-lasting and controllable.
It’s a fascinating challenge
to engineer a standalone muscle
without a supporting organism
that provides this muscle
with an immune system.
These living muscles efficiently convert
chemical energy that comes from nutrients
into muscle contractions.
Living muscles can eventually
become sustainable
and biodegradable machines
that decrease emissions and pollution
all while actually truly mimicking nature.
So all of this,
what I've told you, is possible
with the knowledge that researchers
and engineers have today.
I believe we have to rethink
every machine ever invented
from a holistic perspective.
We have to rethink
what the machine should do
and what it should not do.
I think we want machines
that safely integrate with us,
improve our quality of life.
All the while, we respect nature,
and don't pollute our world
with loud noises.
So let's reimagine machines
to take on forms
we have never thought of before
and discover places
we have never been to before.
Thank you.
(Applause)